that my my thing is I didn't want to die
without you really having met Michael
and and give me a shot I knew you hadn't
listened to me cuz everything you say
you missing in rap I already am I was
already giving you dope you know and it
it I'm glad that you didn't and you turn
death here to me for as long as you did
because it gave me an opportunity to
find the discipline through run the Jews
of how to take two and a half years to
make Michael it took me 10 years of
being with run the Jews to understand I
am building a community I'm not just
talking to an audience it took me 10
years to understand now seven years
because I started about three years ago
took me seven years to understand now
it's time you know and I take it
seriously and and not seriously to the
fact it ain't fun right or you and your
old lady can't get blasted to it and go
to the flame and eat some chicken wng
and see something but I take it
seriously in that I'm trying to give you
or know I've given you a level of
quality that you deserve as a listener
you know hip hop is looked at as
something that does not involve High art
and culture or if it does it doesn't
involve it from a working class
standpoint you know somehow in order to
be of high standard you have to be
Collegiate or you have to wear you know
weird [__] with weird [__] names you
know I'm wearing an ebit field jacket
and I feel stylish as a [__] cuz
this [__] made in America and
it's about football and this is the good
jacket my grandpa put on when he wasn't
working you know and and that's that's
what that's what I'm a that's what I'm
about I take pride in this [__] I take
pride in the fact of knowing that
whether it was Pony or Puma or Nike we
did that we created sneaker culture Nike
doesn't happen without hip hop in the
same capacity it just doesn't starter
starter doesn't happen without I mean
you can name you can literally name
anything it doesn't it doesn't happen so
valenciaga I take this [__] you know
what I'm saying like I I take it that
seriously I love this [__] dog I love
this [__] to my court I love this [__]
with my bones this ain't some [__] I'm
doing on the way to somewhere else you
know you guys have done such a great job
of in a world in which it feels like the
business model of being a rapper
is uh extremely hard if you're
especially an independent rapper right
like it ain't easy it's not easy because
if you're just looking at what a a
million streams pays you right it it
feels like a almost like a hopeless
climb up a mountain in order to really
make a career or be able to just support
your yourself let alone your family
right um you guys have done such a good
job over the last 10 years of um
monetizing the brand right what are some
things that you're doing with
Michael whether it's V obviously the
tour was successful um you know I think
always tell people like if you're if you
got a fan base and you're not and you
don't have a hard weight obviously
people are going to stream it but you
want them to buy the 12in vinyl you want
them to buy a CD a tape man I'm not
going to pretend to be no Mastermind I I
follow I follow my brother currency man
shouts out to him spit man he's who's on
the album yeah him yeah him and two
chains they on my dope booy record
usually your dope boy record you're
hearing we sold the most dope sometimes
dope boys just throw a dope barbecue and
invite all the other dope boys to come
out and you see their cars you get
motivated to do good school cuz your
mama tell you they did good at school
that's why they got it that's how our
record hits me when I the spaceship
views so I got to figure out shooting
something of that but
spitter um I love the the relaxed ways
that him like him and Musa move like cuz
it's just he do what's genuinely him I
remember going down there when he had
the car shop you could go get your braks
and and [__] around to be have a
30-minute com with there you know crazy
imagine getting your brakes done and
you're hanging out with Cur you know
what I'm saying like that's that's the
kind of [__] I'm into so I've just
leaned in the [__] that I I love and
like my wife and I built um in the swag
shop over the last 11 years I bought
that when I was recording rap music I
sold my 95 Impala and bought the swag
shop off Craigslist the first swag shop
and I I've been to that one y yeah I've
been to the first one yeah yep that's on
Rosell Highway we got one on edge we got
one in State Farm Arena we rolling out
two to three next year um you know I'm
like I've had an 11 it took us five to
really kind of figure out what we were
doing I just always wanted to have a
barber shop cool place hang out I have
to wait in line but what we realized
doing Co especially when we closed moms
were dming me like don't close y'all
shops y'all shops is one of the only
places that I can bring my boy I know
he's in the company of good men with
Integrity I'm treated with respect there
was just and then they said man we love
when y'all do the little t-shirt drops
and stuff so we were like man we going
to have to be paying R let's just press
up some shirts and what we realize is
man you are a brand operating as a
barers shop yeah I mean I I think I B I
I got a new era yeah so we got we got
more new er stuff coming we got more
t-shirts and stuff coming we got more
product everything cigarette lighters as
trays cool stuff coming but we're a
barber shop and we've spent some time
figuring out what kind of shampoos I
like I hate to smell girly so it's not
like I'm using my girl stuff I hate the
the I don't want to smell like Old Spice
like my dad you know what I mean so we
developed um I got a shampoo conditioner
thing coming out I got some shaving
cream coming out beer bomm I just got
some cool stuff that you can just buy
when you're at the shop you get getting
a haircut so I'm excited about that to
see what that's going to do because I
know that as a man I don't like going in
the beauty supply stores as a guy when
my Jordans drop I might I might have no
problem paying $200 for the for the
Jordans but I don't want to pay $150 for
a t-shirt what's your favorite Jay my
favorite Jay um um my favorite let me
give you my favorite alltime Nike the 87
Air Max okay you got Air Maxes on now
you got what are
those but yeah so that that's my
favorite Jay's I just whatever I'm
Jordan 3es you like the threes I like
the four to me is the most all around
it's the three or four for me the three
is very uncomfortable but it's just such
a I probably like the silhouette of the
four the best yeah for is amazing man no
it's it's and then yeah you know you
guys just dropped your own Nike SBs yeah
we did we did man we did